Which of the following is incorrectly
matched Dhyana Dena Incorrect Pooch Liya Hai
Incorrectly Matched
Chalo Yath Metol Por Phyra Floridian
Starch Volvox Starch Ecto Corpus Fuco
J Athin Aise
Example Based Questions Aayenge Aap Dekh
Rahe Ho Thicks Is A Member Of
Chlorophine Yes Vandana Yes
Geetanjali Tanvi  Adarsh ​​Very
Good Corporation Very Good Rest Children Quickly
Everybody Very Very Very Good Everyone's answer is
absolutely correct Yulo Frix is ​​a chlorophyll
not too much Will be present there in the form of starch
Incorrect answer which means
correct A correct option is correct Answer
is option number one